[Música]
el parque nacional yosemite en
california está en llamas desde la
semana pasada el incendio forestal está
controlado en un 25% y ya arrasó más de
1000 hectáreas su bosque de más de 500
de juegos gigantes sigue en riesgo
el presidente de panamá laurentino
cortizo prometió nuevas medidas de
austeridad para intentar calmar las
protestas y en congelará el precio del
combustible para los particulares y el
valor de 10 productos básicos
ayudas económicas a 75 millones de
personas para intentar enfrentar la
inflación es la promesa que hizo el
presidente chileno gabriel burín plantea
aumentar el subsidio de empleo y dar
bonos a quienes más lo necesitan pero
primero el congreso debatirá el plan
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
especialmente a este espacio dedicado a
hablar de la actualidad en américa
iniciamos en eeuu los equipos de
bomberos californianos intentan contener
las llamas en el parque nacional de
yosemite y el fuego amenaza a más de 500
escuelas nativas desde el viernes marina
sardiña con los detalles
los bomberos ganan terreno al fuego en
el popular parque nacional yosemite en
california pero las llamas amenazan un
bosque de más de sus 500 icónica
secuoyas gigantes algunos de estos
árboles tienen más de 2000 años
estoy parado justo en frente de chrysler
giant que es posiblemente uno de los
árboles más famosos de la tierra y
tenemos un sistema de rociadores a su
alrededor estamos tratando de brindarle
primeros auxilios preventivos y
asegurarnos de que el fuego no viene
para acá
los trabajadores del parque hacen todo
lo posible para evitar que el fuego
activo desde el pasado jueves penetren
en el bosque mariposa y es que a pesar
de su gruesa corteza las secuoyas
nativas se han vuelto más vulnerables
debido a las sequías y a los cada vez
más recurrentes incendios forestales
consecuencia de los cambios extremos
exacerbados por el calentamiento global
para que nuestras condiciones son
extremas en el oeste hemos tenido años
de sequía hemos tenido un invierno muy
muy pobre en las sierras el manto de
nieve no estaba normal nuestros ríos
están bajos nuestros lagos están bajos
nuestros embalses están bajos y el
incendio en el parque está controlado a
un 25% y ya ha arrasado con unas 1000
hectáreas tras las altas temperaturas de
los últimos días dificultan las tareas
sólo en 2022 los bomberos del estado han
declarado más de 3500 incendios
forestales en panamá el presidente de
laurentino cortizo anunció que congelará
el precio del combustible para los
particulares a partir del 15 de julio
esta es una de las concesiones que hace
para desactivar la huelga que lleva más
de una semana juan pablo y lucumí nos
amplia
la huelga indefinida comenzó el 6 de
julio
desde entonces maestros de todo panamá
han liderado multitudinarias protestas a
las que se han unido trabajadores de
construcción y miembros de comunidades
indígenas para exigirle al gobierno que
intervenga en los precios del mercado en
medio de una elevada inflación exigimos
aumento general de salario reducción en
los precios de los medicamentos que se
acaben la monopolio de los medicamentos
que tienen ser senado al pueblo panameño
reducción de los precios de combustible
y disminución de los precios a la
canasta básica
[Aplausos]
ante las peticiones de los panameños y
luego de reunirse con sindicatos y
organizaciones sociales
el presidente laurentino cortizo anunció
que congelará el precio del galón del
combustible para vehículos particulares
a partir del 15 de julio y espera calmar
el enojo de la población mediante un
decreto quiero anunciar que he decidido
ampliar la medida de congelar el precio
del galón de combustible en 395 para los
vehículos particulares
a nivel nacional a partir del 15 de
julio
igualmente he convocado para mañana el
consejo de abín ete para aprobar un
decreto que congelará el precio de diez
productos
adicionales de la canasta básica otra
piedra tira de piedra la protesta que se
hace más fuerte con el pasar de los días
se ha transformado en cierre de vías
enfrentamientos con la policía y hasta
un paro educativo por parte de los
profesores
las autoridades del salvador han
reportado miles de detenciones desde que
se implementó el régimen de excepción
hace más de tres meses sin embargo el
gobierno de nayib ukulele no está
compartiendo la información precisa
sobre a quienes arresto y donde tampoco
habla de las muertes bajo custodia
estatal a pesar de que ong denuncian
arbitrariedades ariana villacorta nos
cuenta
sigue la guerra contra las pandillas en
el salvador ya van más de 100 días desde
que se implementó un régimen de
excepción las entidades estatales que
han reportado miles de detenciones han
cerrado el flujo de información oficial
aún cuando la legislación indica que los
datos estadísticos deben ser públicos y
este gobierno no ha sido transparente en
cuanto a datos pareció bastante difícil
que
y se logre acumular en las prisiones es
el número de población a generar una
mayor crisis de la que hay ahora hasta
el 10 de julio el gobierno situó los
arrestos en más de 45 mil pero se
desconoce oficialmente el impacto que
han tenido en el sistema carcelario
salvadoreño
tampoco se sabe el número exacto de
detenciones arbitrarias que se han hecho
durante el régimen aunque las
organizaciones humanitarias registran
más de 3.000 denuncias de atropellos y
más de 50 personas podrían haber
fallecido bajo custodia estatal el
gobierno del presidente en allí bukele
dice haber derrotado a las pandillas sin
baño de sangre capturar criminales que
estuvieron que tuvieron de rodillas a
los gobiernos anteriores que tenían
secuestrada a las comunidades que tenían
armamento pesado que tenían estructuras
organizadas de forma casi militar que
tenían campamentos que tenían recursos
financieros armas pesadas y enfrentarlos
y están los derrotando así que hay un
baño de sangre es algo que merece ser
considerado por la comunidad
internacional las pandillas señaladas de
pepe la mayoría de asesinatos en el
salvador poseen unos 70 mil miembros en
el país centroamericano hasta antes de
una escalada de asesinatos y aprobación
del régimen las maras tenían a unos
16.000 de sus miembros encarcelados
según el presidente salvadoreño haití
podría enfrentar una crisis alimentaria
a causa del repunte de la violencia en
los últimos tres meses el programa
mundial de alimentos de la onu advirtió
obstáculos para entregar su ayuda
alimentaria en la capital
andrés granadillo nos cuenta más
crisis alimentaria en puerto príncipe a
esto es lo que se enfrenta a la capital
de haití debido al incremento de la
violencia
esta violencia ha tenido un impacto en
los mercados en el comercio en los
medios de vida y aislado en la ciudad el
resto de haití las carreteras hacia el
sur se cortaron hace un año las
carreteras hacia el este se han cortado
hacia la república dominicana y las
carreteras hacia el norte-noroeste de
east haven carácter de americano paulik
y más de 50 personas han muerto en
enfrentamientos entre bandas desde el
viernes dijo un alcalde local en el
marco de un aumento de este tipo de
violencia en la nación caribeña grandes
zonas de puerto príncipe están
controladas por bandas los datos que
tenemos muestran que la situación en los
últimos 90 días ha empeorado y que
estamos en un punto de partida en el que
haití es un lugar muy vulnerable en el
que ya había un millón de personas en
esta ciudad con inseguridad alimentaria
aguda
las entregas de suministros de las
cosechas como los plátanos no pueden
llegar por carretera porque los camiones
corren el riesgo de ser tiroteados o
retenidos por el camino el programa
mundial de alimentos de la onu dijo que
sus entregas se han visto atrapadas en
el fuego cruzado por lo que ha creado un
servicio de transbordador vía marítima
que lleva a la ayuda alimentaria
importada a puerto príncipe y a otras
partes del país también está utilizando
vuelos cortos para sus trabajadores
sumado a esto la inflación de los
alimentos se sitúa en torno al 52 por
ciento la crítica situación pone contra
las cuerdas en la frágil economía de uno
de los países más pobres de américa
latina' ahora vamos a chile donde los
precios han subido a un nivel que no se
veía desde 1994 por eso el gobierno de
gabriel boric propuso ayudas económicas
para hacerle frente a la inflación el
mandatario quiere extender un subsidio
al empleo ampliar la ayuda económica
posnatal hasta 60 días entre otras
medidas ahora el congreso debatirá las
propuestas desde santiago nuestra
corresponsal patricia luna nos explicó
el contexto de los anuncios y cuáles han
sido las reacciones
pues en un contexto de subida récord del
dólar como se acaba de mencionar que ha
alcanzado cifras históricas en las
últimas jornadas sobrepasando los mil
pesos frente a por ejemplo los 850 que
se cotizaba hace tan solo un mes en
también un contexto de un alza
importante de la inflación en un país
que importa el 100% por ejemplo del
petróleo y un 50 por ciento de los
alimentos pero para la presidenta del
banco central roxana el tema en el caso
de chile la inflación tiene que también
un factor interno vinculado a los
retiros de pensiones que desataron una
ola consumista que se pusieron 50 mil 52
mil millones de dólares y 35 mil
millones de dólares que se usaron el año
pasado se destinaron a ayudas por la
pandemia y terminamos con las nuevas
imágenes del telescopio espacial james
webb que fueron reveladas por la nasa y
que siguen fascinando al mundo se trata
del primer lote de fotografías de alta
resolución a todo color en las que se
pueden apreciar en detalle nebulosas y
grupos de galaxias
hasta aquí las noticias sigan en france
[Música]